here's what would happen if the Earth
had no core
underneath 2 900 kilometers of crust and
mantle lies the core of our planet this
ball of molten iron has a radius of
about 3 500 kilometers and temperatures
of 10 000 degrees that's hotter than the
surface of the Sun
no iron core means we'd have no magnetic
field and without a magnetic field
animals would lose their ability to
navigate Earth would lose its atmosphere
and we'd be blasted by ferocious solar
winds instead of being a planet warm
enough to store salty oceans with
thriving life Earth would be a cold dry
and lifeless desert we would be exposed
to harmful Cosmic radiation from the Sun
you'd likely have to live underground
where you'd be less exposed to Cosmic
radiation so